greetings from podcastville
it's monday the 18th of january
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
[__] draftkings
if there's a week to place a bet this is
the week
you got my man dustin poirier against
the irish [__]
mallet of death conor mcgregor they
stepped
back into the ring saturday night now
if you want a piece of history go to
draftkings
why because they're the official betting
partner of the ufc
and this weekend they got a deal that no
one else could match are you ready for
this
just for ufc 257 don't get carried away
it's your shot at turning one dollar
into 257
that's right you're like joey how can i
pick up the 257 here we go
you better dollar on mcgregor to win by
knockout
in the first round and if he does you're
cashing in 257
you bet a little you win a lot you know
how we do it at draftkings
but don't get distracted don't get
distracted distract him
don't get distracted because we're still
in the middle of nba playoffs next
weekend
and nba basketball at night so head to
draftkings right now today it's monday
let's get the party started right
you already [__] up three mondays in
january
you're not gonna [__] up this monday go
to draftkings
and download the sports book app right
now use promo code joey here's what
you're gonna do
you're gonna sign up to turn one dollar
into 257 dollars
if mcgregor wins by first round knockout
place your bet watch the fight put up
your feet smoke the number have mama
lick your balls
but like i said you got nba and you got
the nfl playoffs next weekend
i could walk you through how you can
[__] walk away you got that 257
and you got four other nfl games who's
better than you
four or two two four who gives a [__]
you're making money cox something
so if you haven't tried draftkings yet
today's your lucky day
download the draftking sports app now
use promo code joey
when you sign up for 157
to win if mcgregor wins by first round
knockout place your bet watch the fight
relax
that's code joey for new players to get
257 dollars
in mcgregor wins by first round knockout
for a limited time only
at draftkings but hey the party starts
tonight monday night
tnt got three [__] games on tonight
and one of them's got a line that's so
[__] soft
anybody could see through it before you
download the app do me a favor
this is the part the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 [__] sucker
go draw a picture indiana new jersey
pennsylvania
tennessee colorado restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a
gambling problem
let's take care of if there's help call
1-800 gambler
and if you're in indiana call 1-809
with it but if you got no [__]
problems let's go [__]
it's time to download this draftking
sports app
use code joey and cash in on this deal
and this is sadly
i'm gonna make you a g note before
[__] saturday and it starts tonight
with three games on tnt
the joint is also brought to you by
expressvpn listen i think by now
you've already seen everything on
[__] netflix even the spanish [__]
but with expressvpn you can trick the
computer into thinking
you're in a different country and you'll
be able to watch just about anything
in the [__] world i think it's called
the dark web
[Music]
you already know a vpn will protect your
privacy online
but it's taken my tv watching game to
the next level my wife uses it
all the [__] time she likes all those
english movies
unlock movies and tv shows that are only
available
in other countries and if it works on
any any service
in over 100 countries netflix amazon
youtube bbc you name it
listen like i said my wife watches all
those international shows
she [__] lives with vpn she loves it
vpn expressvpn
is ridiculously fast it streams in hd
there's no [__] buffering let's what
else do you need here
use my special link right now the joint
expressvpn
dot com slash joey again expressvpn.com
joey and you get an entire three months
for free an extra three months
for free support the joint watch what
you want
and protect your privacy which is the
most important thing
at expressvpn dot com
slash joey so right now you just
downloaded the draftkings app
now go download the expressvpn.com
joey and watch [__] horror movies
watch [__] midgets getting their
fingers cut off
you can watch whatever the [__] you
watch want to watch go to expressvpn.com
joey i want to thank expressvpn and i
want to thank draftkings
let's get this party started you bad
[__]
it's monday morning a beautiful day to
be alive
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
monday morning
uncle joey here feeling tip top magoo
thank you for all the well wishes and
everybody checking in on the knee
it's doing great man i'm way ahead of
schedule i actually walked up steps
uh i got a 90 degree angle on my bend
i've been having pt you know every night
i get a call hello is this mr diaz
we will be over tomorrow at 10 o'clock
they come over they walk me they beat me
to death
i'm doing really well on the medication
guys between cbd lion
the tylenol 650 milligrams
and the oxis they gave me i [__]
alternated them around
and you know what i was a little
panicking because i was running out of
them because they told me that they do
every [__] six hours but i was
getting too [__] up
and i was i was getting too [__] up
that day they lowered my blood pressure
those things
uh tuesday morning thank god my wife
came down the middle of night to check
on me
she [__] woke me up she's like you're
sweating up a stone
i had to take off my sweatshirt take off
my t-shirt
and uh she checked my blood pressure she
had to give me like [__] salted taffy
to bring me back up again so i was like
you know what
they get they sent me new prescriptions
and i've been using
the only time i really use uh the oxy
you know when you need them for
at night at night because you don't want
to wake up at four in the morning to pee
and be in that type of pain you'll never
[__] fall asleep again
so uh i've been all like i said i've
been doing it i've been doing my own
pain management so i rub some cbd on
i take some uh cbd gummies in the
daytime i had two boxes of them i might
as well start eating those [__]
they're 10 calories a piece they've been
great in the daytime
then at night i use the tincture
ah which gives me a little bit more i
could pump
in 5 000 milligrams under the tongue i
got some great great flavor thing [__]
that [__] tastes great so that was my
main concern
going into the surgery and always
everybody's concerned
is is he going to go off the [__]
reservation with the pain medication
thank god i'm not a fan and i knew that
i pretty much
tape it off i started taping off on
friday so
it's [__] monday i feel great that
earthiness you get from norcos
like all that little weird feeling if
you're living in the twilight zone
no i'm not agitated yeah you could tell
i'm not agitated i've been [__] great
i've been
listen man i'm 58 i don't expect
what do you what what do you expect to
be tap dance in the next [__] day
i don't expect that at all it's going to
be some hard [__] work
i got uh today's my last [__] uh
home therapy session this afternoon
this afternoon i got my stitches taken
out and wednesday i started i started my
buddies
[__] physical therapy place so i'm
going right from one place
right to the other you know i didn't uh
google
the surgery i usually google everything
you know i'm a half a [__]
but i learned the hard way when my wife
was having a baby
i googled women having babies at 43
and holy [__] it was the worst pregnancy
of my life
because i basically thought she was
gonna [__] die on the table
so i said you know what if i read
anything about this knee surgery
before i [__] have the surgery guess
what's gonna happen
i'm gonna [__] cancel it because i'll
get too scared
so i think tuesday wednesday i started
googling and i went to webmd
what to expect from your knee surgery
recovery time
exercises and i've been taking the
[__] seriously so
right now in my mind like in my mind i
still have a little pain
i still walk funny i need to [__]
stroll a little walk the whole thing the
crutches but
in like every in their mind i'm [__]
way ahead of schedule so
that makes me feel [__] great so uh
for you guys wondering thank you for all
your support
with the new stuff last week we talked
about accusations
about what it takes to accuse somebody
and what it feels like when you get
accused
i really really thought about it all
week it's been something that's been on
my mind
for almost a year since all this [__]
started how does an accusation start
you know how do you get it confirmed
you know with somebody oh i called my
girlfriend when i got home
that's not good enough you know that's
just not [__] good enough you know
um there's just so many [__] things
when the other night i have a dear
friend that comes over here a lot
uh and sits with me at night and watches
football i mean when i talk about what
dear friends
i'm talking about let's say i go back
with him when i'm 13
and in fact he gave me led zeppelin
the song remains the same with uh
the allman brothers live from the
fillmore on eight track
like it was uh it was some of these
different eight track
and he recorded two albums over it
you know like two albums over the eight
track
so uh he gave me that when i was like
13. so
you know for years i would see him and
go you're the [__] but he did
he him and i were tight tight friends
when i was 13 he would you know he was i
think he's
60 now so we started hanging out when i
was about 13 you know
he had two younger brothers and i hung
up by his house and as i got older
uh he got his driver's license and he
was always a clean guy you know he
always was going to be a [__] cop
but uh he had a friend that dealt weed
he wasn't one of those guys that was
uh you know uptight about being a cop he
just uh
he just wanted to obey the law you know
and uh he turned me onto a guy that me
and him
ended up being good friends and selling
weed for years and whatever that doesn't
matter but
the other night rail came over and as he
was leaving
he picked up a picture of anthony
balzano i don't know if you guys uh
i do the album of the week on patreon
and i did a segment about kiss
and i actually showed a picture of a
friend of mine who had died in the
eighth grade
i had gotten this picture from his dad
before his dad died about five years ago
and uh i got the picture about 20 years
ago and i at first i started
using my wallet because he was my best
friend and i figured if i had my best
friend that close to me but i didn't
want to lose my wallet
and i lose that picture and i never knew
so i just left it at home
and i did like an altar for him and all
my other buddies and
uh the night i had the picture of him
out and joe rail was leaving
and his wife was here and my wife was
downstairs in the basement
and joe rail picked up a picture of
anthony and he looks at my wife and he
goes
look how good looking your husband was
in eighth grade and i go
sorry but that's anthony he goes that's
amazing
i forgot how much you guys looked alike
like we were like [__] twins when we
were kids
they called us both peppa knows you know
because we both had big noses and we
were skinny
he would lose his mind when you call
them pepper nose me
i didn't even give a [__] they had to be
calling they had been calling me [__]
for two years prior
peppa knows it was a [__] break what
i'm saying yeah who gives a [__] about
peppa knows
you just been calling me [__] for three
years so i didn't give a [__]
uh him and i were really good friends
and
you know he died in the eighth grade it
really took a chunk out of who i was
till this day i still think a lot about
anthony
40 [__] eighth grade you know
may of 78 this [__] kid died but one
thing joe said
to my wife you know joe was like wow now
i remember
how much you guys look alike and one
thing joe was saying he goes one thing i
remember about you guys that you guys
were [__] tight
like because you guys had a [__] huge
crew down there
guys when i i thought when i lived on
48th street i had like a rolling tough
crew
when i moved north bergen in 73 it took
me a couple years to go out
but once i went out i attracted a crew
that we were some hard-hitting little
[__] kids who weren't bad kids
big difference we were just hard-hitting
kids we played everything
we played in the woods we played we just
did everything there was to do
we hustled we we went down to the train
tracks this is before the meadowlands
was even built
and we used to cut [__] punks and
sell them door-to-door
punks or sticks that you light on fire
and it gets rid of mosquitoes and [__]
it's like that mosquito spray only got a
lot of on fire and [__]
i mean we just did crazy things you know
we were robbing trains there was a year
there well i didn't even know what the
[__] i was
i just went to martial arts and hung out
with these kids but the one thing
did stand i i don't know how many of us
there were just off the top
of my head myself dominic speciale
michael speciale valentine pharaoh
this was just on my block then on
charles court you had sabatino
dean altman you had the four brothers
that
the balzano's beat up the first time
with the sister you had
pronge the two guys the two kids who the
father was the iceman's assistant
you had a loan of mertens you had the
[__] reasons i mean you had so many
kids
i forget what this little italian kid's
name was i thought he was a [__]
psychic
and my mother wanted me to kill him
because he gave my mother the wrong
information in a basketball game one
time you know you just had so many
[__] kids and we lived and died for
one another
we were out there all day playing and
those girls i still remember those girls
we were all tight in fact till today
it's night this we're talking about
running with somebody in 76.75
today i still talked to lisa and gina
marjorie
uh grace savoya i still talked to so
many girls from that area
because we were so tight that joanne
kellett there was no
sex we were kids we were kids the only
thing we did that was wrong was we
played buck buck
i don't know if you guys know what buck
buck is buck buck is some guy gets
against the wall
and then some guy holds on to his uh
waist with his head going that way and
then everybody holds each other's waist
and you create like a human chain so
let's say you have eight people
bent over like they're gonna take it in
the ass i don't know if you've ever seen
this game
so it's eight people bent over like
they're gonna take it in the ass holding
on to each other
with a guy standing on the wall he's
called the pillow
and then let's say you have six people
on a team they have a team of seven
okay so it's seven people against six
bent over because the seventh guy is the
pillow
he's holding and he's coaching he's
telling you hold on mike
don't bust your [__] because what people
usually do so what you do is
you take a run and jump
you come running like 20 [__]
like 20 feet you think like a running
jump and then there's one guy
bent over you push off of him
and you fly into the air until you land
on somebody so
let's say our goal is to land on mike we
know mike has bad knees
our plan is listen everybody land on
mike
mike can't hold all this up so then boom
boom we land on mike the next guy goes
he lands on me
now i got like his three guys on top me
i'm punching mike
i'm squeezing mike's ears mike's like i
don't mind people on top of me
but why are people poking my eyes out
and all this [__] we were kids we were
really poking each other's eyes out we
were just like smacking each other and
[__] like there's no big [__] deal
so this is the only thing we did then
the girls got involved once the girls
were like we want to play we're like
girls
i hope you know we got into because your
tits are going to be squeezed
all that [__] and like as long as you're
not rough with us we don't give a [__]
i think the girls played with us like
two or three times and when
they got together and said [__] you guys
you guys i think we ripped off a girl's
tit
we almost ripped off a tip because you
have to land on that
they also had a so here are these girls
playing buck buck
and now they're bent over holding on to
another girl and men are landing on top
of them
and we have to break the chain so all we
would do
the worst thing we would do those girls
in those days was like pull their hair
and they'd be like ow who's the [__]
[__] that's pulling my hair
when i get out of this i'm gonna [__]
kill you [__] queen and all this
we were just you know we were just
that's the worst thing we did to those
girls
if we bought a four pack of wine coolers
they got beers if we bought beers they
got beers
if we had weed wait do you think i would
still talk to lisa
gina marjorie and grace if we weren't
tight with those girls growing up we
were super tight with them
whatever we did at night when we went
over like the hill to union city
and west new york we would always take
us take them with them
and we'd watch their [__] back we had
a girl kathy god rest her soul
i was tight with i mean we were all
[__] tight
okay i moved
to mckinley in 73 i go to sacred heart
school for boys but
i don't actually go to mckinley
until sixth grade comes now i don't have
to tell you how i felt
uh first day of school i knew some
people but most importantly i knew
anthony already
so i knew nobody was gonna [__] with me
anthony
was in the class i was in the sixth
grade anthony was in the fifth grade
anthony had a brother who wasn't a sixth
grade named jimmy
i was tight with him too and he had a
brother in the eighth grade named
political pete
i was tight with him too but i was
having a brother older than him
big frank i was tight with him too but
my main dog was anthony
me and anthony were together every day
me and anthony were all doing
already doing like little scams like
betting we would like i don't know we
didn't do
nothing big time we'd rob like a bag of
concrete
you know we were just kids we were just
two [__] [__] kids you know
i loved him dearly he loved me and
brother it was we were together every
day
it was two things when i walked home
from school
he lived a block still north from me we
had two options
either i was go to his house or i would
wait at the bottom of my corner
and he would walk towards me and we
would go to charles court or liberty
avenue or wherever we were going to
[__] play a 38th street court
38 street court already was dominated by
older kids
there was like third you know 12 of us
10 of us
and but we didn't want to mess with the
kids at the park because they were older
they were drinking already
they would [__] they wouldn't bully
us they would just torture us
make us [__] play basketball with
them and follow us and all this [__]
no big [__] deal all right to make a
long story short
i in the seventh grade
i finished my sixth grade year and i go
to the seventh grade
and i had a teacher named earl kingwell
earl kingwood was a very very good
teacher he was a scumbag but looking at
errol king well today
the reason i like reading is because
earl was a little heavy with his hands
he smacked a few students and he got
beat up for it there's a thousand
stories i could tell about her
but this ain't about earl today uh
errol was rough on me in the seventh
grade i don't know what it was
i'm not saying he was i think he was
heavy with me because
he saw the potential in me he saw i
wasn't a stupid kid
and going into the seventh grade i had
no problems with school at all
never had a problem with school but then
something happens to little boys in the
seventh and eighth grade
i fell in love i fell in love with this
girl i mean i mean
just i don't know how it happened i
never had interest in girls
i mean i thought girls were always
beautiful i thought about the day i
would like
go on a date you know [__] like that but
at that time i wasn't looking for a
girlfriend or nothing
i hung out with this kid his name was
alby um
we were both speed demons you know our
connection was
we rode bicycles and you know
we rode motorcycles and at night we'd
all walk up the hill
uh eddie lamenka mario arias alby
just all of us weren't the motorcycles
we were just innocent stupid kids
anthony
frankie pete balzano we were into
motorcycles
and every night we'd walk up 38 that's
how we ended our night
after all the basketball all the
football all the
[__] you know running up and down
hills at night we'd meet
and instead of getting high those days
we'd walk up 38th
street to carvel and we'd get a cone or
a chocolate shake
i'm talking about 10 12 of us and then
we go to a kawasaki dealer there was a
kawasaki dealer
on 39th and kennedy boulevard then we
basically go to jerk off all over each
other you know what i'm saying like
oh someday i'm gonna have that bike you
know we're not gonna get [__]
none of us are gonna buy [__] i had the
ability to buy [__]
because i would just make money at my
mother's bar at the time i probably had
like a
yz-80 uh not kawasaki i think uh suzuki
made a yza don't quote me on this or
tweet me if you do know the exact ones
it doesn't matter again we were all very
tight and then
one thing happened one day boom i go to
alby's house and he's got the cutest
sister in the world
she's in the other she's in the seventh
grade
she's in the other class and i don't
know
i don't know i i just
i think like maybe january or february
i we used to all go roller skating on
sundays
like a bunch of [__] at the paramus mall
we would all get together and go roller
skate
kids i did it all you know i don't want
you to think that i did it all
uh 10 12 15 of us a parent
two three cars you know one parent had a
station wagon or whatever
and i just kind of took a liking to her
and
i drew up the [__] mustard you know i
drew up i
i got like flowers one day and i asked
her if uh
she wanted to be my girlfriend and she
said she got to talk to her family
i was like what the [__] did i get
myself involved
she talked to a family her family said
yes
you could be her boyfriend you could
start by doing little things going to
the movie theaters
and taking the grandmother which i've
talked about how much i [__] hate it
to this day
it was the only time i did it with it
was the only woman i did it with
and i felt just [__] like a [__] but
it was old
cuban tradition so i took a
i don't know i wish i remembered what
stupid moore went to see and the
grandmother came
i think i took it to like two or three
movies and the grandmother came
and then since i was friends with the
brother i was allowed to go over to the
house
and the deal was this we were gonna just
kiss and make out
no sex and then uh
june before the eighth grade announced
that we were a couple
you know right away i i don't know i
felt something weird
why do we have to hide and all this [__]
you know you already went to your family
and told them they kind of like giggled
at us we were too young
you know she was into donny and marie
and on friday nights i would go over
there and watch donnie and marie
and then i smartened up and i'm like
[__] you donnie and marie
i'm staying at home and watching red fox
sampling sun and [__]
uh the show with pretty prince
i forget what the name is chico and the
man you know
anyway none of this really matters i'm
just giving you background on what
happened
so june of whatever year that was comes
and she comes to me and says you know
i've been thinking about it
i don't think i'm ready to have a
boyfriend yet and i'm heartbroken
i always i was never in love with a girl
before i'm [__] heartbroken
i [__] you know fall to pieces
like velvet revolver i just you know i
don't know how to take it
but what had also happened throughout
the year was that i had fallen in love
with her
so much that i had just
i i didn't do anything else i didn't go
to karate
i didn't work on my math i didn't work
on my geography
i didn't work on a lot of things i
barely read
i was in love i was in love head over
heels what do you want man
i was a stupid romantic uh
and in the meantime my grades slipped my
mom didn't know
not only did she not wasn't gonna date
me
but i also had to go to summer school
that didn't stop me if you guys know
anything about me that didn't stop me
i you know got on my hands and knees and
prayed to her that she would [__] you
know
please reconsider being my girlfriend
blah blah blah
and we still messed around uh not me we
had
never had sex let's get that straight we
kissed and i sucked the titties maybe
and that was it one day she really
looked at me and said look
i don't because we got caught playing
hooky and my mother went off on her
and it was just a lot for both families
she didn't like my mother called her a
[__] and [__] in spanish
my mother called her mother a [__] it
was just 9.0 for everybody here
so we decided just to break up we're
like listen this is causing too much
problem
i immediately uh was heartbroken i think
i stayed home for a week
and i had to re-prioritize not only that
i
failed summer school i didn't fail
summer school
i played hooky from summer school to be
with her and i thought that carmine
could
cover it up and help me out i ended up
getting [__] left
back you have
no idea how bad i feel listen to all
these words i'm telling you because
you're gonna have to make a decision at
the end of this
i got left back so now i got left back i
got no girlfriend
my friends are laughing at me behind my
back not anthony you know
i had tight friends and i'm like hey man
it happens [__] that [__] you'll get
another girlfriend you know and i'm like
i don't want no other girlfriend i want
nikki
you know i'm a [__] half a [__]
i'm a catholic kid at that time i had
been in a couple fights but i really
believed
i would never ever do anything
that you know like at that time i just
didn't have it i didn't have any
anger in my heart or anything like that
so
i sucked it up guys i went to summer
school
i got thrown out for attendance and then
i realized
that i was gonna get left back anyway i
took my lumps
i avoided going to charles court you
know i said that's it i can't go to
charles court for a while
because i'm too in love with her i want
to get over and i
dove into basketball dove into
basketball
head [__] first going into seventh
grade my
seventh grade my second time that's all
i had
i wanted to play basketball i loved
going to karate i
redove myself into karate and i [__]
rededicated myself to the books i was
back i had miss welsh in the eighth
grade
you know i went in there and talked to
her she spoke to me
and told me you know that uh we'll be
watching you if you fall
behind or have any problems this doesn't
have nothing to do with it
but i'm i'm fine i get over her
i'm playing basketball i'm back in a
groove of things
don't get me wrong it must have taken me
90 days to get over
you know maybe let's say october
november i'm over i see her every day at
school you know
we kind of talk and i was friends with a
brother
so you know what man i had to push it
aside
at that early age in the seventh grade
the second time
i had to learn that you know this is
part of breaking up with people you have
to move on
and that's it so we immediately became
friends you know she was a cheerleader
on the basketball team there was no
getting away from her
you know we just became friends again
and this time we were just friends
she was becoming a beautiful girl in the
eighth grade uh and this in the seventh
grade i still wasn't really
dating that had taken the [__] wind
out of my sails
i did become a fan of like you know
classic love songs you know
baby come back any kind of fool
could see there was something all that
type of pop
all that [__] i became a fan of and i
dedicated to her
but somewhere along the line i just got
over i got so involved in basketball
you know i wanted our teams to be so
good i got so involved with hanging out
with anthony
and his family and dominic speciale you
know what
nicki went away like whatever so the
winter came
uh the winter came and went and then the
spring came
right what comes after the winter the
spring right so the spring comes
at this time i'm still a speed demon you
know i got
uh a motorcycle i've got a 10 speed i've
got
one of those bikes that just you go like
this the [__] bar whatever the [__]
and the high thing and i have to ride
around like those [__] dudes you see
them like uh all the gang movies and
[__]
like my debo bike i had like a debo bike
right
deebo died right debo the guy from
friday and we had a bike i had a couple
different bikes
but turns out the kid next door to me
valentine pharaoh
was a tremendous and i mean again
another nice
sweet kid he didn't even know what he
was doing but he just like working on
bikes
you could bring him a bicycle and he
would [__] take the whole thing apart
i mean he was
brilliant he knew [__] that i didn't
even
think you know and he could take the
insides of a [__] rim apart
and tell you where the [__] ball
bearings were slipping
and i mean i'm like what the [__] are
you talking about but just learning with
him and sitting with him
i learned little things he would say i'm
not just going to do it to you for free
you're going to have to meet him with
the same [__] age he would be
[__] way ahead of me blah blah blah
blah and he would fix up these bicycles
between you and me the gizzies doug
jimenez all these kids were stealing
bicycles and they would bring them to
given that terrace and we'd buy them you
know
three four dollars ten dollars five
dollars and then our goal was for
valentine to do work on them
and we'd take them up to union city and
sell them that was our little
scam at the side me anthony valentin
all of us that was our little scam so i
think charlie gizzy and doug jimenez
brought us three bikes a week
and we'd redo you know i'd go buy a can
of primer
spray paint you had to take the vin
number off the bicycle
so you either had a we had a [__] car
oh my god it's
guys you know it didn't it wasn't a
vietnam it was like a 10 digit
identification number
like when you first bought a bicycle
those days if you were a decent kid
you used to have to go down to a police
station and get the bicycle registered i
don't know if you know this
if you got a view back when people were
decent
and things were decent as soon as you
got a bicycle you were instructed to go
to the police station how
[__] much times have changed you were
instructed to go to the police station
and [__] register your name and they
would give you like a sticker
don't steal this bike [__] you those are
the first ones you stole
you know because people felt secure with
the sticker like
it was like a restraining order like
it's he's not going to hit me
next thing you know you're oj's wife on
the concrete floor right
no it's the truth because people think
oh i got a restraining order i'm safe
yeah see how many people have died
restraining all this don't believe the
hype
but all these kids believe that they had
the [__]
if they had this little gold sticker
from north bergen police department or
west new york police department
or whatever police department your bike
wasn't going to get stolen
you were done we had the [__] stuff
to take the [__] sticker off
and then we valentine figured out some
chemical to take the adhesive off so you
wouldn't
see the sticker if anyone would sand it
down
and then there was a kid next to him
clemens that that family had fleas
like they all had what do you call that
[__] uh when everybody has to have a
crew cut
lice they all have lice so you got to
like [__] stay he we got a social
distance from him
50 [__] years ago yeah i swear to kid
the clemens everybody had lice it was
well known in the neighborhood
in fact the spent the white kids would
tell the other white kids
hey clemito kenneth hill that means that
he's got bugs even the white kids learn
how to speak spanish
to code other white kids about the
clemences and the clemencies were a nice
family
but michael clements was the [__] when
it came to a bicycle
and so was valentine pharaoh so they
could whip up a bicycle within two
[__] days
a bicycle would be you could bring it
you could bring a [__] microscope i
don't give a [__]
you still couldn't tell that was your
[__] bicycle that's how good these
two [__] morons were
at doing bicycles so i live right next
door
i was neighbors with valentine pharaoh
and next to valentine pharaoh was
michael clements
so every time my garage door would open
i'm exaggerating here three days a week
i would have either michael clemens or
valentin
they would already be outside with the
bicycle upside down you ever see those
guys the bicycles upside down
and they're spinning it and they're
putting [__] oil on the thing
every time i went out of the house let's
[__] just for the chase
just for the clarity let's just assume
they did it four times a week
so every time i would go out i'd go wow
you got a new bike and he would
[__] be going look at these rims and
you would hear it spinning and his shirt
would have oil on it
because you put oil like three in one
oil and when you spin it the shirt would
he would have like a street gold from
the bicycle from the [__]
all his shirts had the same [__]
streak on it from the oil so
you know every time i go out he'd go
cokes what are you doing
i go nothing he go cokes take this bike
for a ride when they tell you to take a
bike for a ride
that didn't mean to go to the top of the
[__] hill and come all the way down
90 miles an hour
that was to ride sitting down
right under control to ride the bike
sitting down just to see how it felt
and then you stood up and you pedaled
you know and then you brought the bike
back and you go valentine it felt pretty
good and then
he'd have like three of us try it like
he was you know
me michael and dominic or anthony he'd
have three of us try to [__] bicycle
i get on the bicycle one day and i come
out one day
and he's got a bicycle he's got a a 10
speed
a regular silver ten speed
he had just finished painting it it was
silver
with black tape on the handlebars it was
like an english racer
like a long thing like that something
that we had never seen before at that
time we were still into these [__]
things you know
uh he had an english racer and it was a
black nice seat
with black electrical tape on the
handlebars he put silver caps at the end
i mean valentine was a bad [__]
and he spray painted the bike
silver i
didn't think twice of it i come out
valentine what's happening miss doltino
was out there what's going on latino
puerto rican charlie whatever the puerto
rican [__] i told you the
puerto rican nelson was out there i come
out
and i'm not thinking anything he goes
joey coco
you want to take a take i already was
taking my bike out
and he goes no no no i want you to take
this bike out see what you think
i take the [__] bike and
i go for a ride i come back he goes what
do you think i dig the [__] bike
but i think there's something wrong with
the handlebars
he gets the big wrench and he [__]
whatever
he goes take it again like okay i take
the ride i go downhill
and i make a left this time and i can
see again that
when i made the left there was some
hesitation in the steering
so i go let me keep going i go i go to i
it was it was 38th street park
given that terrace charles court then
liberty avenue
all the action was on charles court
liberty had a little bit of action for
kids
vanitchex phillips vinnie neglia
vinnie warhead not really the canelos
but everybody would meet in the middle
in charles court so i take my bike
i go to charles quarter again i need to
do another left when i make the [__]
left up that block again
i see there's something wrong with the
bike i hear kids playing
i go to the top of the block it's
charles court there's 16 kids out there
girls you know and they always were
doing something
you know [__] stick ball or a buck
buck or
hide the [__] kick the can they were
always doing something
so i put the bike down without thinking
anything of it
and um now charles court is a cul-de-sac
with a middle in the middle is an island
that has two houses on it
one facing that way and one facing the
other way
no big deal i go up the corner here and
i'm on this side
let's pretend this is the island it
comes all the way down and then this is
where the leads off
back to the streets to and you go over
to either the park or whatever but it
was basically a cul-de-sac
with a little island and it was such a
big block
that three sets of kids could be playing
on it
and nobody would know i could have
acidic kid at three o'clock
which was usually the case the dobson's
the robsons
lived at one o'clock sabatino
lived at 12 o'clock there was kids that
lived next to him i said them before the
ones that were
the iceman's friend's son and then there
was elona mertens
and the aries that went down this block
here okay
so you could have 20 kids playing at
once
was the girl that i dated that i was in
love with
that now i was over with like i was she
had gone her way
and i had gone my way we were still dear
friends
her brother was still part of our little
bike crew
i don't think her brother was there that
day i think her brother was riding
motorcycles with frank
and we were on the black because alby
was a year or two
older than me i was
the same age as nicki now that we have
gotten left
back we're still the same age she was
just in the eighth grade and i was in
the seventh grade
we had a cool relationship obviously we
played basketball
uh i played basketball she was my
cheerleader
nothing bad happened
we got along we went to the movies
together we got slices of pizza together
our uh seventh grade year obviously we
went 0-7
it was the worst season of our school's
[__] life so
boom no big [__] deal everything was
cool
we're playing it's gotta be april
march april around there
because it was still beautiful it was a
beautiful day out
and i don't know what we're playing
you know i love the lighting i don't
know what we're playing
and somebody yells cokes were going for
a bike ride
nikki's taking your bike
so i'm on the other side i'm on by
sabatino
and i go what the [__] you saying and he
goes we're going for a bike ride
nikki's taking your bike i go no
because the bike the handlebar was loose
so instead of me chasing them that way i
tried to cut them off
the long way the it wasn't even a long
way
it was the same distance i tried to cut
them off at the bottom
before they got to union turnpike
that's the main street to go back and
forth
my job was to i was going to cut her off
and go nikki be careful
all i wanted to do was to tell her
that the bike was off okay that's it
just before you get on that bike mike
the [__] steering wheel is off don't
come crying to me
you know i know how to handle it i know
i've i've been riding these [__] up
bikes forever
but i don't know what she's thinking you
know we all rode bikes together but
still
let's just be what let's just be safe
than sorry
as i'm running for them they think
that you know how people run away from
you when you're a kid like
my god he's coming to get us boo
whatever so i'm running towards her
and sabatino and whoever else is on the
bike
and as i run towards her she looks up at
me
and sure enough she's gonna make a right
the thing gets stuck and right for
12 feet from me i see
the bike twist and i just see her go
over the handlebar and i see the bike
land
on top of her guys she [__] goes over
the handlebar
the mic lands on top of her
she actually gets up and looks around
and we're like are you okay
and then after she said yeah we kind of
[__] giggled we're kids
we're like that was a tremendous fall
you know how kids would
this is what kids would do that's a
great fall holy [__] are you okay
so we picked her up we got her up we you
know she was fine she got back on the
bike i go
i wasn't chasing you to not let you know
i was chasing you to tell you that the
handlebar was [__] up
this is what i was chasing you for i
wasn't chasing because i didn't want you
riding the bike i don't give a [__] if
you ride the bike
nothing happened everybody witnessed
what i witnessed
everybody that was on those bikes let's
say at that time there were six kids on
that bike
nikki was number seven i was number
eight eight of us
witnessed what happened as a matter of
fact after she fell and the bike landed
on top of her
was when all of us got there with the
bikes we all missed the
the fall by five seconds and we're like
are you okay she
was looking around and then we're like
what the [__] nikki and that's when
everybody started giggling
in the circle we picked her up
took her home i never thought nothing of
it i never thought nothing of it next
day i go to [__] school
i [__] get into my seventh grade
[__] uh classroom that i got left
back and marone was my teacher
as a matter of fact she was in the
eighth grade i was in the seventh grade
and mr brown pulls me out the hallway
and he goes did you hear about your
girlfriend
and i don't know i don't have a
he goes you know what i'm talking about
nikki ariza did you hear about it i go
no what happened she goes she's in
critical condition in the hospital
she uh had a blood clot in the middle of
the night they had a ticket to the
hospital emergency
blood clot and she's on life support
she's gonna [__] die
and everything in me [__] stopped i
mean
i loved that girl you know uh i was over
her
but i loved her the same way i love kate
quigley today the same way i love
felicia
you know i i learned at an early age
that you can't [__] everybody
that's why i still talk to gina that's
why i still talk to lisa messina
that's why i still talk to all those
girls because an early age
i realized that you can't [__] everybody
you gotta have females
as your friends they enhance your life i
felt really bad about the nikki thing
when they told me in school that morning
so right from school i went right to the
[__] house
knocked on the door my mother was there
they asked me what had happened
i told her what happened you know we
were all there
other kids are coming to check out like
a bunch of us went over
to see what the hell had happened to new
york we all told her what
happened she didn't remember
you know she was in a coma so we waited
for a couple days
and she came out of a coma and then they
actually we i think they allowed they
didn't allow us to see us
she didn't want nobody to serious her in
the hospital because they had to shave
her head
so you know i'm not thinking anything of
it guys
i'm just feeling bad about this girl you
know she's in a coma
she's coming home when she comes home we
all go over there
i went out of my way i bought a box of
exotic [__] fish
you know those uh you know the the nice
red ones yeah
i didn't just buy them yeah in those
days before covered and [__]
you went up to the chinese store and you
stuck your hand on the thing
in a bag you counted out i bought 25
fish
and you paid them 25 cents whatever i
wanted above and beyond
i bought a roses i bought her a a case
of the goldfish
you know we all chipped in and got her a
card the whole [__] thing
and i went over there and the mother was
cool the
everybody was cool you know we all
talked i'm sorry she had the bandage on
and then the mother took me again
downstairs and said so tell me what
happened again
and she goes listen she got on the
[__] bike
the bike was around you know the
steering wheels weren't working
right and we chased her to tell her that
the steering wheel wasn't
working right she thought we were
chasing her to get her off the bike
and she went over the bike and that was
it and ended at that guys
that was it do you know like [__]
three days later
i go to [__] school and
one of the teachers pulls me aside and
he goes we need to talk
and he goes this kid came in and he goes
he didn't see it but from his angle
he thought that you might have pushed
her or whatever and i go
that wasn't the case because we were
never there
we all saw the thing he goes well he
says well from he
from where he was watching i go yeah
yeah
we got that and she had landed already
and the bike had fallen on top of her
and that was it i didn't i go no nobody
pushed her
that that that's a lie nobody pushed it
nobody could even push it nobody was
close to her
but then the room was started getting
out coco must have pushed her
coco wants to push the coco must have
pushed the guys through this day
i'm telling you i didn't push i went to
actually i even went to nicki
and i go nikki let me ask you a question
did i push you and she goes you couldn't
have pushed me because
you were 10 feet away from me alright
she goes
the last thing i remember is looking at
you
and flying in the air boom
that's it i graduate i go to eighth
grade
she goes to the freshman year now let me
tell you how good looking this girl is
freshman year high school
she wins homecoming queen with no hair
that's how beautiful this girl was i
love this girl with all my [__] heart
love it with all my heart wanted to
sleep with her wanted her to
from for her to be my first girlfriend
the whole thing
brother it just didn't happen okay so
we're friends
i get to high school i see her in high
school every day
we talk we share weed we share
money the whole thing what
i'm telling you now is the jokey side of
it that you're going to think it's a
joke that i told on joe rogan
when she recovered from that surgery
before the surgery she was just a skinny
13 year old girl
when she recovered from the surgery the
bad part of that surgery was
whatever part hit her brain made her
tits grow
i wish this was a joke i wish this was a
joke
and i mean not make a tits grow to like
you know
nice tits i mean they were like triple b
and then on the flip side she became
what's the word when you become
when you become kind of a hoary uh
she started sleeping with a lot of guys
the reputation
promiscuous the reputation on the sleep
on the word got out that she started
sleeping with a lot of guys
okay so my mother dies
we're still friends my mother dies at
79. this all went down in 77-76
my mother dies at 79 i'm moving with the
benders
and 19 [__] 80 i'm supposed to
graduate high school in 82.
she's supposed to graduate in 81. hear
me out
i'm sitting at the benders watching
football one night
and the door knocks and mr bender goes
there's a broad wait for you at the door
i'm like are you [__] kidding me
no girl has ever called for me i thought
this was a mistake
when i go for the door it's tricky nikki
with big pics on a mini skirt [__]
looking tremendous
i know what's happening and she goes can
we talk for a minute
and she tells this guy that she was
dating
uh was going to take it to the prom if i
could take it to the prom instead
[Music]
i was between me and you guys i was so
like this had to be 81 right i was on
drugs
you know i was on acid every day
um i was still living with the vendors
so it was before i got through another
benders
april of 81. so i was still living with
the vendors obviously
and she's like would you take me to the
prom and all this stuff she thinks she
goes if you technically prom
i will [__] you to death and i'm like
like guys i was scared
i'm not gonna lie to you guys she was
way advanced like
you know like i could tell she had just
got an information she was a woman
she was [__] men already like that
was her thing that she wasn't dating
high school guys
she was [__] men that's why she said
that the guy
she was that's supposed to take it to
the prom
couldn't take her because [__] uh i
don't know
his [__] wife i don't know so i'm
like
you're gonna [__] my brains on i mean
oh my god she's telling me all this
stuff she's gonna suck my dick
at that time i had never gotten a
[__] or nothing like that i'm like
wow
she scared me so much that i hid from
her
like i hid from her like i'm like you
know what after further consideration
i'm not i'm not [__] messing around
with this chick this is not gonna happen
so i told her some excuse about [__]
why i couldn't take it to the prom but
it just wasn't for me i didn't even went
to my own proms i'm gonna take some girl
to [__] prom
i told her i couldn't go and i didn't go
to the prom and that was it
never saw her again maybe saw a year
after that i saw in the neighborhood
facebook [__]
myspace opens up one day
and you know like we all did we all went
on myspace and
we saw people and one day who do i see
but nikki in a ninja [__] suit on
right with like
only her eyes and she's like doing
karate things and i'm like is that who i
think it is like
i read the profile and sure enough i
look in the pictures
and it's her and i i don't know what we
did in facebook
on myspace and on those days if we
friended people
followed them or whatever i followed
them
i think a week later i got this [__]
huge note from her
saying that uh i ruined her life
you know that her life was never the
same she could never hold a relationship
with a [__] man
because of what i did to her and all
this and i'm like
what the [__] i'm thinking this is like
a girl from boulder
like maybe i dated a girl in boulder and
she got it wrong and maybe
no this is who this was so i immediately
you know hey man i i don't know if what
the [__] is your problem
but i loved you i mean what is your
[__] problem and she goes well
i thought about it throughout the years
and i felt that maybe you did push me
and i'm like
no you didn't say that so [__] the
next day
you know me dog listen they're gonna
shoot accusations at you every day
right you could do two things if they're
real
you could address them if you're
whatever me the ones that piss me off
are the ones that are completely fake
if i did something i'll cop to it you
know me if i did something
i'll cop to it i don't give a
frenchman's [__] what are you gonna do
now i'm 58 years old what are you
what were you gonna do back then i mean
i was one of those guys
when i was 28 i already had it but i
already knew that if i
you're not going to accuse me of
something you're just not going to
[__] accuse me
and none of you guys nobody knew about
this no but nobody knew about this
this is just this is just so before you
read an accusation next time or
you read it with this type of mind an
open [__] mind because this is what
happens to people
dog i lived it i have [__] lived it
so i had to call a friend of mine the
next day from that neighborhood and go
hey do you still talk to her
call her up and see if we could have
changed numbers and talk
my girlfriend called me my girlfriend
that girl called me
a week later she goes i took her out to
coffee blah blah blah blah
she feels that you were chasing her
i don't know what the [__] she felt you
know uh
but her life has never been the same and
she put that [__] accusation on you
and i go can i ask you a question you
were there that day
and she goes yes i was i remember how
hard that bike landed on her
i go to you in your heart did you see me
push her and she goes from where i was
standing
none of us nobody was close to her
nobody was close to her not even by a
[__] long shot
were they close to her so she goes i
want you to do me a favor i don't want
you to ever think about this again
this is why till today i am so
i understand accusations
but i don't like them and i don't like
down time
because it lets you think of those
stories like i thought about that story
10 million times and i still had to
check my heart
to check to see if i could don't do
something like that there was no way
there was no way but in her mind her
life had become such a [__] bowl
that it retracted back to me in 75
with a bike [__] incident and you
know what i got so crazy about that
situation
i interviewed like six people like i
recall people
talked to them a little bit and then
said hey man i got to talk to you about
something
do you remember when she fell off the
bike and they were like yeah we were all
there
i go did you all of them anybody who was
i think i conjured up four witnesses
five witnesses
three of them were girls they were like
nobody was even close to her
when she landed we all swooped up on her
and picked her up we were all that got
there on the same time
today she doesn't want to be my friend
whatever uh
it hurts my feelings it does because
we were so tight growing up but in the
other way
on the other hand it just lets you know
about accusations
what i can you know [__]
i [__] hate him i [__] hate him
and it's not just towards me it's
towards anybody
because i understand what you're feeling
when you didn't do something
and you got falsely accused people
sitting [__]
what about people who sit in [__]
prisons for 30 years
until some poor little white dude comes
up with a stitch of dna you ever see
it's always
it's always a black dude who's in jail
and it's always a white dude who gets a
piece of dna
to save his [__] life think of
something like that happen to you
so that's why when it comes to
accusations guys
at any level whether it be he sent me a
text message
that he did this did he touch me any of
those accusations i reacted because
it sucks being falsely accused of
something until this day
it hurts my [__] feelings until this
day
i'm like maybe i have something coming
back to me karmically
because of that but i could look you in
the [__] eye
and tell you that nobody touched that
chick
and in fact if anybody would have saw me
touch her anybody in that neighborhood
they would have raised their hand
because that's the type of neighborhood
we're from we'll tell you the [__]
truth
so when i talk to you people are
accusations
next time you read an accusation about
something that happened 30 [__] years
ago
think of two things there's an i don't
know if you've ever read the sammy the
bull book
samuel bull has an interesting [__]
book the one that he sold they made the
money from
he has an instant an interesting chapter
in that book
and it's about after he joined the
gambinos he went
and had to be somebody's understudy he
had to be this guy's understudy every
day
the guy made him report to him the guy
was an older italian guy
and all the guy cared about in those
days was
[__] fruit and growing vegetables i
forget what the guy's name is in the
book
he had his [__] cigar and he he had
his fingers whenever you went to see him
he'd have his
his feet rolled up uh his pants rolled
up in the mud this is why i'm using the
story
just so this is how i look at things
he said that he got to become a gangster
under him because his tato aurelio
that was the guy's name was taro taro
taught him two things
taro taught him one thing that was very
important that i learned growing up
okay he said that while he was there
every day
somebody would come in with a beef
like uh mike would come in and go
[__]
uh joey took me on the road he was
supposed to give me 500 but instead he
gave me 400
you know he [__] ripped me off and
then
then tyler will go right mike go home
let me talk to joey the next day
and see what joey has to say you know
and
without mike's knowledge joy would come
the next day
and tyler would ask him what happened
why is mike manage here and he goes i
took him on the road
and i paid him he said that
you said you were going to give him 500
but you ended up giving 400 i go
no ask him again i told him
that if i sold out the shows i'd give
him 500.
i didn't sell out the shows that's why i
gave him the 400 but i still paid him
his dough
i still paid for all his dinners and i
still took great care of him
the next day taro stands for mike
and he goes i had joey here yesterday he
enjoyed your company he loved you to
death
he said everything went great he said
that he said to you
yes he'll pay you 500. if he sold out
and then the guy would go oh i didn't
[__] hear that part
and he goes you know from sitting there
all those years
and watching that i started
i started doing something extra and
that's listening
listening listening to two sides
and see where the f bro there's two
sides to every [__] story
okay i i don't know if you guys watched
last week there was a big thing going on
with carlos on
bobby lee guys i [__] love
carlos mancia i i love carlos carlos
in the very very beginning helped me out
a lot i don't like
i and you know how i feel about bobby i
love bobby the [__] death
i don't like uh
you know it's a beating record it
happened 20 years ago move on with
your life what i don't like about it is
that still
after 20 years carlos is still like
weaving yeah he's chuckling and jiving
carlos we love you
it's been 20 years just say yes
i stole the joke and move on i watched
that
you know somebody called me and said you
watch carlos on
bobby lee at least bobby had the balls
to [__] confront them i go
i tried to confront them during the
warm-ups
of you know like when somebody comes to
a podcast and you're setting up the
lights and you're asking
where am i sitting i confront them then
i go
let's talk about the joke stealing and
he looked at me and he's like
what joke stealing are you talking about
and i was like i'm not even gonna go
there
like i after all these years
if you're still [__] banging your
head
saying to yourself i was not involved in
it i can't thought they even did a
documentary and put you on it and
and called you a joke thief or whatever
i'm not mad at carlos
i don't care about carlos carl's a nice
guy he worked it out you know whatever
he still goes out and does comedy he's a
[__] road warrior
i don't care but even the other day
listening to it you know they hated me
because
mitzi gave me the name ned
oh i i started running the light because
dice and mooney were running like well
why you came from
you don't do what everybody else does
you do what you do
so they go along with you like i i could
walk off here
and you could call you could contact the
store ask them in 23 years i ever run
the [__] light
one time by mistake i ran the light i
got involved in a joke
i ran the light i got off stage i
apologize to the uh
comic and with the kamikado stage i
apologize to him again i apologize to
the [__]
the chick in the boot i apologize to
jeff i apologize to everybody when you
run the light it's very disrespectful
but that's not what we're here for we're
here talking about accusations
if you got accused of something you got
two options you could either [__] lie
or you could say yes this is how i did
it
this is why i did it let's move the [__]
on
and life is done but for you to sit
there and start all these years
for me with the nikki thing
it makes me want to cry like why don't i
almost broke down and cried before when
i was telling you the story
because i cared for her that much
that i can't find that much that much
if she was just a girl and i [__] or
whatever
no i cared about it that much and i came
for her more
after i dated her because i realized how
much of a [__] jerk off i was
for falling in love it was too young to
fall in love but the point of all this
is
accusations accusations
[__] suck but here's let's go for the
main course of this whole thing was
where there's smoke there's fire
so also remember that
now if we were sitting here having a
conversation
of three chicks flying through bikes
around me
it's pretty tough to joey to get himself
out of that one not that i'm getting
myself on anything
i'm just explaining to you how it goes
when i got accused in 85
of robin and joanne liggio's house a
very dear friend of mine
again what year is it right now 21
2021. this is 1985.
that means we're going to go on 36 years
ago was rob during
the night of a [__] football dinner
or some [__] which they'd usually do in
january or february
i was accused of it i lived in cresco
new jersey
i called the cop north bergen police the
next day when they accused me
i said i got a [__] alibi i don't
know what time they stole it
but i couldn't have robbed it because
there's three different [__] people
looking to kill me in north bergen
i'm not going to north bergen especially
rob a family i know
but they had the balls to say i robbed
them they made the accusation
some people believed them some people
didn't but guess what
i never got mad at the people that
believed them i never got mad at the
people who took their chance
who took their back why do you think
because when there's smoke there's fire
i'm a [__] thief
so yes i robbed michaels i had robbed a
couple things
now i got no leg to stand on do you
understand what i'm saying to you
so where there's smoke there's fire so
next time an accusation comes out about
an actor a comic a fireman
somebody close to you i don't give a
[__] it's true
use logic first before you make your
final [__]
before you go in there with your words i
see people condemning people online
and this is what pisses me off i want
you before you
before you agree with that accusation or
disagree with that accusation
i want you to think about both [__]
sides think of both sides think of the
accuser
and the chick or the man accusing them
think of how the [__] they feel
maybe they didn't do it maybe there was
a chance that they didn't do it
did you ever think of that i always
before i [__] dive into something i
always like to look around
checked on and said when i found out
about ron jeremy did i rip them off my
wall
i didn't have them on my wall i mean on
the podcast no
i talked to two different porno
producers who told me
horrible stories that i did not know
about that you didn't know about
that nobody knew about that gave me
the power to rip that picture down with
ron jeremy
but i didn't rip it down before that
just because once they arrested them
you you're coming down once i hear
stories
and they get confirmed then i make my
[__] uh
hypothesis which best base basically
is an educated guest and i attack
so when they try even when they tried to
go after me this year
if you look at that video there's so
many things you could attack
what are you attacking what are you
attacking
was it joe rogan laughing was it 20
women
was it sucking my dick before the joke
yeah you didn't even know what you were
attacking
you didn't know even know what you were
accusing ah i'm accusing him of laughing
i want you to think about it nine months
later
that they were accusing poor joe of
laughing
of laughing that's how bad of a time we
got
and he addressed it i don't give a [__]
i laughed so what who gives a [__] and
they move the [__]
on and that's what the problem is today
you get accused of something
you didn't [__] do it you [__]
stand up and you fight for yourself
the same way i've done for years i've
done a thousand things
if you come at me right now and accuse
me of kidnapping can't do
well you can't i've never been accused
it couldn't happen i've been accused of
kidnapping
but not convicted of kidnapping that's a
big [__] story
i've been convicted of burglary big
[__] story
so if you accuse me on a burglary if you
say to me right now joey my house got
robbed across the street right here in
jersey
yeah i could be a a suspect because
robbery was in my [__] circle you
understand me
but no don't accuse me of something that
i wasn't like a tree jumper
or something like that that that sucks
being accused of a tree jump but rape
and all that [__]
that [__] sucks so next time you buy
into one of those things before you buy
into it
do all the [__] research you can okay
in my case i did research for all these
guys that you couldn't do
because i'm actually i was living in l.a
at the time
and i could ask around and i could see
you people were just going off
assumptions and videos and whatnot get
the full story
next time a comic comes to your town go
to that show pay for a ticket
invite him out to dinner talk to him get
his opinion on it
and see what the [__] went down and what
didn't go down
this is why i don't like accusations and
i don't believe in them
and that's the [__] podcast it's
monday
the 18th of january it's martin luther
king day
one of the greatest men of all [__]
time he set us [__] free he
straightened this out
until [__] whatever anyway who gives
a [__] about all that [__]
i just want to bring you the church
today on a monday let you know i'm doing
great
i'm feeling great and that's a story you
didn't know about me a lot of people
didn't know about me that till today
it bothers me and the bother that was
that it was a false clan
if it was true [__] it it's true it
doesn't bother me there's a lot of
things i've been accused of
that i didn't do and that i was so far
off the path of doing
that it didn't even make sense again if
somebody robs you or something's missing
in your house
i'm a suspect i can't get myself out of
that one that's the [__] facts
i love you [__] have a great
[__] monday have a great week
on patreon if you want to see the album
of the week
last week i don't know what the [__] it
was i don't know what it's going to be
this week
but we're just having a good time over
there [__] i don't know what my
next stand-up date is
we're just trying to get up all through
all this [__] covert
all i know is i'm gonna try hard this
week and
finish my first chapter maybe a
paragraph or two away
it took me three weeks to finish a
chapter i should be ashamed of myself
but dog
i did it thanks to you guys so if you're
writing a book maybe we could write this
together
we're all in the same dog house we all
bleed when we get cut
i love you guys with all my heart
welcome to week three
of january and i will let you knows i
will post it exactly when
i'm finished with the first chapter but
here's a sad thing about it
as i looked at the book last night
there's like 18 more chapters
i'm in [__] hell i'm never gonna
finish this
but anyway i love you guys with all my
heart i'm gonna stick to this that was
this is my goal
for 2021 and this is a goal we'll be
sharing together
if you want to tweet me and let me know
your goals
be more than welcome if not go [__]
yourself have a great week
uncle joey loves you and now for a word
for my [__] sponsors
all right you [__] i want to
thank you again for listening to the
church
we had a good time i got to talk to you
some [__] that nobody's ever heard
before
but you heard it today hey anyway before
i get out of here
the joint has been brought to you by
expressvpn like i told you in the
beginning
you've been in lockdown for almost a
[__] year i think you've seen
everything on netflix already by now
right or wrong but with expressvpn you
can trick the computer into thinking
you're in a different country and you'll
be able to watch just about anything
in the world you already know a vpn
will protect your privacy online but
it's taken my tv
watching game to the next level better
yet my wife [__] loves this [__]
between the horror shows and the english
movies
unlock movies and tv shows they're only
available in other countries
and it works with any service in over
100 countries for example netflix amazon
youtube
bbc you name it they [__] got it
like i said to you my wife goes upstairs
to a little nook at night
sometimes i go upstairs and i hear these
[__] english people jumping and
that's what she's watching something on
expressvpn
and it's ridiculously fast it streams in
hd
and there's no buffering and it works
for every person and every device in
your home
it's as easy as pie to use even a guy
like me i'm a [__] dumb [__]
just push one button to change your
location and you're watching rick and
morty and [__] friends
are you kidding me or what use my
special link right now here it is grab
it grab a pen
express expressvpn.com
joey and you can get an extra three
months for free
did i just say free yeah [__] free
support the joint
watch what the [__] you want protect
your privacy all
under one [__] umbrella
expressvpn.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
you ready for this word money [__]
aka draftkings
ufc 257 mcgregor
poirier and there's a couple other
fights on the card that are tremendous
but forget this this is what draftkings
is doing for you this sadly
mcgregor steps back into the ring right
if you want a piece of history you're
going to go to draftkings
not only are they [__] the best
sports app around
but they're also the official betting
partner of the ufc
and this weekend they got a deal nobody
else can match for you are you ready
listen to this one just for the ufc 257
it's your shot
at turning one dollar into 257
that's right it's that easy you bet
mcgregor to win by knockout
in the first round and if he does you
bet
you be cashing in 257 [__] dollars
that's a grammar blow a half a blow job
and a bag of weed and some coat and some
[__] cocktails all right
there you go on you nobody knows nothing
you bet a little
and you win or not and then you win a
lot you know how we do it at draftkings
but don't get distracted because i'll
tell you what you're still in the middle
of the
nfl playoffs and you still got nba
basketball tonight
we're gonna make some money we got three
tnt games alone
plus we got a couple other nba games
plus a couple college games
and all you need to do is pick one
winner to get your bankroll started
you roll into saturday you're ready up
five six hundred
bam you pick up your 257 who needs
[__] unemployment
top body to shove that check up his ass
you're making real paper
so head over to draftkings right now
america's top rated sports book
to check out all their promotions and if
you haven't tried it yet
what the [__] are you waiting for
download the draftking sportsbook app
today
now it's safe secure reliable most
important
it's your [__] money deposit and
withdraw at your convenience
download the top-rated draftking sports
app
today right now use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
you cannot be that stupid j-o-e-y
and turn one dollar into 250
if mcgregor wins by first round knockout
nice enough
that's [__] beautiful place your bet
and watch the fist [__] fly this
weekend
that's code joey for new players to get
dollars if mcgregor wins my first round
knockout
and there's a limited time only go to
draftking sportsbook right now but
listen let's not worry about sally let's
worry about how you're going to make
some paper tonight
because as far as i'm concerned monday
is fun day
we're starting tonight with three tnt
games
download the draftking sportsbook app
pressing code joey
and lock yourself in for ufc history
with 257
one dollar turns into 257 that's better
than the [__] picket
and here we go here's the part the
lawyers make me read
you got to be 21 older go go go get a
skateboard go do something
we're gonna playboy magazine and make
your face turn red you ain't gambling
here
new jersey indiana pennsylvania colorado
tennessee
restrictions apply you see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you've got
a gammon bomb
that's a different story there's help
you got to call 1-800
and gambler and if you're in indiana
call 1-809
with it i don't want you lurking around
here with a [__] kissing death
problem but if you
if you're all clear [__] it download the
draftking sportsbook app
use code joey and let's make some
[__] cash
the third week of january i want to
thank draftkings
i want to thank expressvpn but most
importantly i want to thank you
[__] for always having my back
stay black have a good [__] week and
i'll see you wednesday morning
tip top [__] magoo
there you go what the [__] you think
you're dealing
[Music]
so
you